pensemos que todos se habían despertado
muy temprano porque el partido arrancaba
a las 7 de la mañana ahora local y
tenemos que tener en cuenta que tal vez
en otras partes del país No pero en
Buenos Aires eso es un madrugón las
panaderías abrieron más temprano para
proveer de facturas y de pan a la gente
para que la estuviera para el partido
los niños podían entrar más tarde a la
escuela o Ver el partido en la escuela
La familias en la medida de lo posible
se reunieron frente al televisor y hay
muchísima expectativa respecto a este
partido porque se consideraba uno de los
partidos fáciles del grupo para
Argentina Así que la verdad que
sorprendió mucho este resultado Ahora se
reactiva la vida en la ciudad por
supuesto el mundial es cada uno de esos
partidos y está rodeado por la vida
cotidiana Pero la realidad es que
sorprendió mucho y escuché muchísimas
quejas respecto a cómo se está cobrando
el fuera de juego en este en este
mundial Y cómo afectó específicamente a
Argentina que tuvo un par de goles
anulados por fuera de juego que muchos
consideraban que de no utilizarse el
sistema que se utiliza hoy hubieran sido
convalidados Natalia espera ahora a
argentina se le dificulta con esta
derrota del camino para alcanzar sus
objetivos mundialistas
puede ser un golpe moral los jugadores
ya estaban diciendo que bueno que
terminó que no se dio como se tenía que
dar y hay que mirar hacia adelante a mí
me pareció un comentario que estaba
dando vueltas interesante que es un
comentario optimista algo así que si hay
que elegir un partido de primera ronda
para perder Tal vez sea el primero que
puede servir como una suerte de
empujoncito para un equipo que venía tal
vez demasiado confiado con una una
seguidilla de invictos importantísima
que se acaba de cortar de forma Tal vez
un tanto inesperada con Arabia Saudita
pero el fútbol es fútbol Solo queda ver
cómo sigue este mundial para Argentina